u.s lawmakers have reiterated their
country's rock solid commitment to
taiwan in a surprise visit to the island
five lawmakers from both the republican
and democratic parties met taiwanese
president sanguen earlier on friday
their visit comes amid the worst
tensions in decades between china and
taiwan china has repeatedly sent
military aircraft and ships into
taiwanese territory through the past
year in what analysts view as
intimidation tactics
the visit by the u.s delegation is the
third by lawmakers from the united
states this year this is what their
leader said
our commitment to taiwan is rock solid
and has remained steadfast as the ties
between us has deepened
taiwan is a democratic success story
a reliable partner and a force for good
in the world
the visit will come as good news for
taiwan in this year of rising tensions
with china the united states does not
recognize taiwan as a country but is
still its most important arms supplier
taiwanese leader cyan spoke of the ties
between the island and the united states
in terms of the regional situation
taiwan will continue to step up
cooperation with the us uphold our
shared values of freedom and democracy
and ensure regional peace and stability
and for more on this i'm joined now by
my colleague william yang from dw's east
asia bureau in taipei william how
important are such visits for taiwan
yeah so today's visit and also the last
visit earlier this month both focus on
the dialogue between us lawmakers and
the defense minister
defense officials here in taiwan so i
think this is actually a very important
reassurance for the taiwanese government
and also the officials over here that
washington is very interesting a more
concrete and consistent and also a more
in-person dialogue
to talk about security measures not you
know
there are no details that were being
revealed obviously but i think the fact
that these consistent exchanges have
been focusing more on the imminent
threats coming from china or in the
region that will allow taiwan to
actually have a more concrete idea about
where the us government stands and how
much support they can count on coming
from washington let's talk a bit about
the chinese threat now the u.s is
legally committed to providing taiwan
with the military means to defend itself
from a potential chinese attack but the
us has never openly committed to coming
to taiwan's aid militarily in the event
of an attack is that the assurance that
taiwan wants but the u.s is not willing
to give
i think that taiwanese government right
now at least is very uh practical they
know that the us has
a lot of complicated situa political
factors that will prevent it to openly
be militarily committed to defending
taiwan so what they are also telling the
domestic audience here in taiwan is that
the biggest uh the ultimate
responsibility of defending taiwan will
risk with the taiwanese people but the
u.s is committed to continuing to supply
more modernized weapon systems and also
helping to train and also having
security
sessions that the taiwanese
soldiers can actually learn from their
u.s counterparts about how to operate
and how to use all these modernized and
advanced weapons in a
more battle-ready situation
uh now william we've spoken about this
uh earlier now this year so far china
has i think sent in more than a 150
warplanes into taiwanese airspace and
taiwan's defense minister also warned in
october that china could essentially
mount a full-scale invasion by 2025. now
given this warning and these rising
tensions how are taiwanese people
reacting
on a day-to-day basis i would say
taiwanese people are still not too
worried about the fa the immediate
danger that china might launch a
military attack i think the fact is that
they understand there are more
complicated factors that will
have to push china to that limit and
they know that the bottom line for china
is to actually try to reunify with
taiwan without having actually to resort
to the military option and also uh i
think the there is an interesting
increase among the younger generation
about the
uh willingness and also the
determination for them to actually join
the military trainings and also to be
ready to uh
help and uh
jump into a battle in case that such a
situation developed to that level and
the government is actually thinking and
planning to increase the frequency of
military trainings for uh usual citizens
so i think uh this is going to
allow taiwan's
society to be mentally and also i think
realistically more prepared but at the
same time they don't want to panic
themselves into a situation where they
live in fear every day
where does china come in in all of this
william how does china view these
actions and does it impact taiwan in the
short term
so china definitely do not want to see a
more stable and frequent and consistent
exchanges especially between security
officials between the u.s and taiwan and
they have again today
use a warning to say that the u.s should
not try to play the so-called taiwan car
to trigger and provoke china uh but i
think for beijing this is not the
situation where they try to use all
different kinds of ways to isolate
taiwan and to increase the intimidation
against taiwan is actually backfiring
for them and they are probably starting
to realize that but they have no way to
back off and try to soften their stance
obviously under xi jinping so in a lot
of the cases especially in lithuania for
example we're seeing china's continuing
that very hard-line way of retaliating
against countries that try to build up
more closer ties with taiwan but when it
comes to the us i think china finds
itself very
uh like
out of sort almost you know like they
don't really know how to discourage the
us government from uh like downgrading
or like stopping all these uh increased
exchanges so i think uh they will have
to figure out their own way of trying to
deal with this uh more normalized
interaction between the us and taiwan
william yang from dw's east asia bureau
in taipei always a pleasure talking to
you thank you so much for joining us
today
thank you